greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by on it listen if you're looking
for supplements this is a way to go
between the shrimp tax immune that's
what keeps me afloat on all these
disgusting plane rides why like the
other night I went to fly the [ __ ]
Columbus the plane was coming in from
England had people with turbans at
Japanese people with face masks on and
[ __ ] I had a bunch of weird looking
people now you know somebody dropped the
german out of 300 [ __ ] people
especially the plan is coming off from
whatever I looked at cake Quigley and I
popped for those shrimp TECA meals and I
walked on that plane and I was the
biggest I had the biggest dick on that
plane cuz I knew I am gay I ain't
getting sick and look I'm back five hour
flight with a bunch of [ __ ] germs
there and back this is what shroom Tech
immune does never mind shroom tech sport
never mind the [ __ ] alpha brain just
go to islet dot-com impress Church BAM
and get 10% off your first order also
thank you people I've been seeing a lot
of you guys asking me questions about
the Fujiki tremendous especially you're
a fat [ __ ] a-five and a-six they're
tough they're durable and these little
young kids could hang on the [ __ ]
collars all day long [ __ ] that go to
Fuji Sports calm right now and press in
church boom another 10% off delivered to
your house the best keys they got mats
they got rash guards that they always
got a sale on something going on go to
food you sports right now that's what I
use I love them [ __ ] people
pull on me tug on me Fuji Sports calm
right now 10% off put in the word Church
there you go kick this [ __ ] melee
it's Monday the 23rd of April and metal
God's the best oh man Judas Priest the
reason why I opened up with that as my
mother my brother my musical [ __ ]
mentor dean del Rizzi went to see Judas
Priest last night what's the review
brother
smoking man it really good yeah you know
they first of all the [ __ ] show was
packed it was at the big one the Nokia
Theatre they changed the name Microsoft
but holds I think about 8,500 seated and
that thing was fooled of the gills and
then their stage show looked like an 80s
like they spent money like a lot of
bands out there going cheap now they
got a couple screens over the amps you
know these guys had a [ __ ] show man
they put the money in and killed they're
playing old [ __ ] running wild sinner it
was like one-two punch
running wild into sinner as I go I
already got the money's worth right here
right there yeah yeah and the lineup was
tremendous oh they had Saxon which to me
is one of the greatest you know new
waves of British heavy metal bands you
know Saxon with denim and leather and
Dallas 1:00 p.m. motorcycle man those
guys are underrated man underrated I
never really got into them I was passed
I was like into something else but when
they were out there killer it was like
at the time an amazing that one would be
why we had except the may look silly no
much you're right Jackson you're right
yeah yeah that stuff yeah yeah you know
you're right a heap as an old man yeah
yeah yeah nobody write that [ __ ] man
Saxon is just they got the singer his
name's Biff Byford and he the guy can
still write now he's probably like I
don't know we look at it the guys
probably like 7b - what about Howard how
did he sound
he sounded amazing victim of changes
that was the only one they didn't do
they did a an old song off staying class
but they didn't do victim they de Saint
- no yeah oh yeah I think yeah that's a
to talk yeah in 67 67 what about you
said at the end
Tipton came out yeah then the last three
songs metal gods you what was the other
one he did living after midnight and one
other song he came out it was amazing
now they did they went off and then boom
he just appeared by himself on stage all
dark just a spotlight on the people went
crazy and he whipped into metal gods I
was doing the moves had the shades on
the leather he looked great played great
it was awesome to see him you know this
thing's you remember in your life this
thing as you do and then people remind
you and you see your friends expression
when you get to 50 yeah 40 you see your
friends my
on their menu I was such a Sabbath Led
Zepplin guy like that's all I needed
he's a saying at one point in my life
that was all I needed that my buddies
turned me out the one at Skinner this I
have but Street survivors was just so
good yeah but I was still like loyal to
them and then one day I'm in study hall
and this kid Steve running that I still
talk to the kids of my nieces I'm going
to a wedding August first in Denver I
mean you know then my family the right
that time little did I know they were
gonna adopt me yeah me and him were in
study class and he passed me the
cassette to unleashed in these and I
remember taking her home gone I am now
listening to this junk
oh this is [ __ ] junk really Judas
[ __ ] priest what kind of name is
[ __ ] that yeah you know at that time
I started that little [ __ ] Catholicism
mentality like yeah I wouldn't listen to
master reality I didn't like that Pope
on the rope at the end the end of the
rope
you think he's a fool I wasn't Internet
yeah yeah and I put something made me
put it on and I took the long version
like usually I put one song on I could
tell you like the dish it's just not
gonna work
yeah I let the whole cassette run and by
the time they got this Center that's the
one I forget what's I like what side was
on the cassette I forget that order [ __ ]
yeah but I knew when he was like this
said aha yeah guitars came in and the
victim 'changes [ __ ] took me to a
different level
oh and just on the strength of those two
songs it was like a quick transition I
became a priest fan the first priest al
my boy was I went gave it to set back
and one on least in these yeah and I
could not believe how great they sounded
like like we grew up on live music at
house you know the other day I was in
Columbus and I felt like talking about
Paige yeah I'll tell you what the
biggest kick I got for me was growing up
between the ages of 12 and 17 really the
is that my mother was alive 16 I'll tell
you why because you have to put them
together to be allowed to do and that's
something that we don't have in this
country no more called the midnight
movie oh yeah every Saturday there was a
midnight movie the movie theater if
there was two movie theaters a safe
there was Laemmle yeah they would have
two movie theaters going one would
definitely be the rocky humping every
time at night every time and the other
one would be at that time
song remains the same it would be the
sauna is the same Pink Floyd live at
Pompeii yeah Neil Young Whitten the crew
they had a movie that came out for
awhile boring is [ __ ] yeah you know even
high on acid you bored to pieces but the
new young came out with Crazy Horse bad
that's great movie came out I think
there were a couple bands who had movies
the memorable two were Pink Floyd live
at Pompeii and some Romanians are saying
they probably had an eight [ __ ] eight
[ __ ] movie rotation at this Fairview
cinema but we had but I tell you what
movie they did have a midnight one
Saturday because it was just
overwhelming
yeah Apocalypse Now Oh went to the
midnight and it was just heavy [ __ ] like
duty like a midnight when that double
barrel sunshine is peaking like when
that acid is peaking when you're
dripping yeah you're freaking out on the
bus you're getting off the bus you don't
even know if it's a red light or a
yellow light or green light you just
walk across the street your friend has
to pull you out of the street cuz you're
tripping yeah you think the cars 30
miles or what 30 yards away but he's
really three feet away uh-huh
like that's how sizzling we'd be uh when
we'd stand on line for that movie
theater and it wouldn't just be us yeah
if there was 80 people saying
60 of them with tripping balls just like
we do with the same acid from the same
neighborhood we got it and sneaking
booze into bullsh MIT and those flat
vodka bottle yeah get the big one bullsh
MIT's at the silver label kids down the
pants yet write down the [ __ ] pants
and you got something inside the drink
it with I had a friend who would just
drink the silver label straight I was
never a vodka straight no snack bar
needed no smell that [ __ ] you would the
once the movie turns off yeah once the
light went down Lee you would have 60 30
of these check catch people flipping
caps during the movie up in the air so
you're tripping on acid and also you see
a [ __ ] thing flying through the air
people would take the big caps off the
caps
fly gonna flick them and they would fly
through I could never do that
yeah decided all right dad be trippin
your balls off and all of a sudden thing
will go flying he thought it was a
[ __ ] you thought it was a [ __ ]
flying saucer it's amazing I like to
think that like all the times have
changed I just the kids weren't doing
that but I was just one of those 20 kids
who went sober got a diet coke and a
small popcorn and like did not like I
just I I went to one movie high in high
school and it was it was hysterical but
like I just didn't I don't know I don't
know why I didn't do it oh the main
movie the midnight movie was just the
best because you were like out late
stopping yes had a movie yep ac/dc let
there be rock we did not have that yeah
later on though they had that I'm talkin
this is yeah 775 through 81 yeah these
were the prime years of midnight films
movie houses that specialized in three
film afternoons
yeah episode of especially in San
Francisco yeah on the Main Street off
the Tenderloin was I think his mission
right busy Street yeah yeah right there
in that first intersection there was a
movie house they used to play three
movies for $2 dozen you wanna kill an
afternoon yeah yeah and
going there at 11:45 and walk out there
at 6:15 you just sitting good guys I did
it a thousand time yeah I did it a
thousand times that's how I would keep
up on them and they do a Clint Eastwood
festival oh yeah eight seven oh eight
fast
conquest the Royal [ __ ] name oh that
one mate move that Pagani and I couldn't
even put a most racist thing I've ever
saw I didn't feel like that when I
watched the first time I watched out of
the eights I felt like a kid yet how did
i watch the new one with Mark Wahlberg
I'm like this is the most racist [ __ ]
thing I have ever seen in my life yeah I
haven't seen that but those early ones
were just psyphon listen bro [ __ ]
conquest of the Planet of the Apes when
they took the masks off I need the
tunnel in New York City now I'm living
in New York City yeah so I'm [ __ ] in
seven and I'm living in New York City an
awesome this gorillas living underneath
the [ __ ] buildings cuz they showed
the trains and they showed the Statue of
Liberty I take oh yeah yeah what's the
plan Liang state that the statue was
down it's New York after the apocalypse
and it's run by Apes and one
good-looking [ __ ] white dude yeah I
forget the blonde head do it I forget
what his name was
Charlton Heston was the first one was he
yes the first one that was so great man
man the second one battle beneath the
planet's mist of my favorite yeah
whether worship in the nuclear but a
nuclear bomb they take the skins off
[ __ ] is creepy oh that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
real whoa wait a second yeah and they
had that creepy music plant
oh yeah it was beneath conquest yeah and
then returned to the planet it was five
oh yeah a day man my mom dropped me off
at like 10:00 a.m. I am dog and yes it
that those six 6:30
Oh eating popcorn and [ __ ] yeah but
how much of an ugly of it was the acid
that creep do because what that time no
you weren't doing I just can't if you
want in any afternoon you wouldn't be
doing acid and you'll be smoking pot it
was that thing waiting for our parents
just to have a cheap babysitter yeah
sense
nobody would bother you there you go
with three your friends you leave
they're [ __ ] fired up you sit there
and watch Dirty Harry
I'm the second one oh yeah you leaved
their [ __ ] I remember taking a Cuban
refugee one time and that's the first
time he was like what you Clint Eastwood
yeah I heard about him in Cuba maybe so
I wanted his oh it's like two bucks
bigger than Magnum force he yeah that's
right he didn't speak English it was
like Dirty Harry Magnum force but it was
the scene that scene when he goes into
the coffee shop oh I love that goes back
is the car smoking yeah the was he says
he says got the car running he says how
would I know he goes tailpipe he goes
ooh that's terrible exhaust pouring out
of there no the other one
see if you can find the bleed when he
goes in Dirty Harry coffee shop scene
watch okay shall sing it out when he
goes back into the coffee shop this when
you're up think of being a kid yeah
watching this but his for me I want my
godfather and afterward yeah went
someplace to eat and while I'm watching
the movie he goes put your hand out
under the table ah I go okay and he put
some [ __ ] a 44 Magnum in my hand oh
he had one he goes this is the gun that
you saw in the movie like hold his gun
oh I gotta be I don't know how old I am
when I went to see them I just dump the
keys some bullet and he gave me the gun
to hold my dick was so hard
Harry yeah yeah TV oh this sudden impact
is the later one oh okay let's check
this out check this out you notice oh
yeah check this ah yeah
god I love him dirty areas were my
favorite dude
look at the shade although this a that's
not okay hold on yeah yeah oh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is it
oh yeah I love this
this is killer oh good
oh yeah I love this you never saw this
digitally no I haven't yet this is great
oh my [ __ ] god how much sugars Jesus
Christ
great scene
it's good
now you're a [ __ ] kids you know yeah
you lift them weights real good with
that cop now I want everything money
watch this raise everything helps a
little party
[Music]
so I love this big head suck dick yeah
yeah every day for the last 10 years
loretta there has been given me a large
black coffee
today she gives me a large black coffee
when it's got sugar
a lot of sugar
I just came back to complain
how you boys put those guns down he's by
himself no back up no no part and nobody
wanted to be a Spartan for guys well
we're not just gonna let you walk out of
here
who's Weezy sucker
Smith and Wesson and me
oh hi guys
[Music]
this is cool
[Applause]
this is what American was big like this
was it go ahead make my day
now get any better no it doesn't yeah
when you were kid this way you went to
see oh you didn't go see a super [ __ ]
hero look what I saw as a kid yeah time
for [ __ ] superheroes [ __ ] your capes
you know go ahead make my day then he
does the other one week explains the
baton tool I don't with all this
excitement I don't know how many shots
are fired
the coffee is psychic and then the guy
goes I gots to know
and he [ __ ] back the hammer oh that's
one put that only six shots or five man
that's six shots of five this is too
much this is what was my hero if you
show this the kids they won't go into a
school cuz they know [ __ ] like
this exist yeah yeah they're thinking
now superheroes existence [ __ ] how the
kind of superhero gets there that
[ __ ] Harry this is crazy this is it
right here okay this is the all-time
best scene by Clint Eastwood of all time
insane this so go oh yes
and all in Sanford now this is all San
Francisco yeah all San Francisco that's
what's amazing you a kid and he's
shooting movies Yeah right all over town
I hear ya
visual oh and this guy did every [ __ ]
movie in the world every movie every
every money not much he was the [ __ ]
salesman in the outlaw Josie Wales Jaffe
is that ten forwards to a park across
from the bank turn I love this it's my
favorite
[Music]
we are careful engine running I don't
know how can I tell sauce fumes coming
out of the tailpipe that's awful
look at that pollution
do
to be a favor will you
all this telephone
wage department Tellem inspector Calahan
thinks there's a 211 in progress the
bank
be sure intelligence in progress right
geshe they're just genius the acting's
him the cunnies would destroyed the
Saturday absolutely destroyed you says
absolutely from the [ __ ] eager
sanction to this yeah so [ __ ] I mean
he destroyed the [ __ ] 70s than half
of the area every which way the clues
every which was the one with the fight
yeah yeah yeah yeah with the ape the
gauntlet American is again
I love this scene
[Music]
taking dudes out and he always shot
black people and nobody ever complained
the NC double-a CP it was just accepted
that Clint Eastwood shot black people oh
my god yeah great gotten to know that's
my favorite and that guy did a thousand
movies that black dude that is a
thousand movies
I love others cars driving around it's
great it's not in any rush
no you just walk it hey walking this guy
do a thousand [ __ ] movie really there
James Bond movie I did plenty of time to
grab that I know what you're thinking
did he fire six shots or only five
well to tell you the truth and all this
excitement I kind of lost track myself
I being this is a 44 magnum the most
powerful handgun in the world and would
blow your head clean off you've got to
ask yourself one question do I feel
lucky well do you punk
Hey
I gots to know
let's hide the film open
that's how can you believe this should
leave leave this is I think
Russian press in this [ __ ] guy I love
Josey Wales with the Indian chief oh
this is my all-time favorite this is one
of my all-time favorite scenes as a man
it's one of my all-time favorite scenes
as a [ __ ] film buff like that scene
with him in the Indian to me is just I
don't know who wrote it
the guy's just [ __ ] look at all the
classics he did dude you know just just
a line of awesome right there just
listen to his verbage how he says it
oh man this scene this is just American
this can be this is 77 this is I was
[ __ ] than 14 the first time I saw
this I saw this in a movie theater and I
nearly died like I walked out of there I
wanted to be an Indian like that that
was done like I gotta figure out how to
become an Indian like this is death this
is the only thing we have yeah like I
wanted to be part of this [ __ ] you know
he jumps in now this guy's son has
reached out to me this guy did two
movies this and he was the Indian and
you name it One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
my favorite Oh chief chief oh oh oh
I always wanted to look like Eastwood in
these movies you know walking around
town like that with a hat [ __ ] dirty
beard I've seen this scene I gotta say
500 times I've watched this movie yeah I
watched it three times two weeks ago is
not like I watch up to this well I'll
leave and I know it's coming back on at
11:00 yeah I'll come home and catch the
beginning of this with the woman in
Kansas the salesman this has 50 [ __ ]
good scenes when the Indian questions
them how men look at this look at this I
am Ken bear's chief spit yeah I'm Josey
Wales
I have heard you're the gray Rider you
would not make peace with the Bluecoats
you may go in peace I reckon not
I would meeting you lord I write I'd
wear one of those I think I'm half
Comanche I love the beard today with you
live Liam I need so hard for men like
you and me it's living it's hard and all
you've ever cared about spin butchered
your raped governments don't live
together people live together
governments you don't always get a fair
word or a fair fight while I've come
here to give you either one or get
either one from you I came here like
this so you'll know my word of death is
true and my word of life is then true
[Music]
the bear lives here a wolf the antelope
Komachi and so will we
I will only hunt what we need to live on
same as the Comanche does and every
spring when the grass turns green and
the Comanche moves north you can rest
here in peace put your syllabi kattiline
jerk beef for the journey the sign of
the Comanche
that will be on our Lodge that's my word
of life and your word of death is here
in my pistols there in your rifles I'm
here for either one these things you say
we will have we already have that's true
I ain't promising an extra I'm just
giving you life and you're giving me
life and I'm saying that men can live
together without butchering one another
god damn sick it said that governments
are achieved by the double tongues there
is iron in your words of death for all
Comanche to see and solder is iron in
your words of life no sign paper can
hold the iron it must come from men the
words of ten bears carries the same iron
of life and death it is good that
warriors such as we meet in the struggle
of life or death it shall be life mr.
masterpiece Joe a dog I would frame
right there if I had to cut my hands
a-shaking Indian saying I'm afraid have
to do it yeah I'll keep it together and
breathe ah right look at this [ __ ] my
brothers and they're shaking left hands
which is [ __ ] really weird yeah yeah
this is the bat this is just [ __ ]
tremendous man you don't understand I
hold the American Indian like if I had
to join I don't want to be part of the
organization I won't even [ __ ] go
over and hang out with those guys over
comedy whatever where the podcasts are
and [ __ ] yeah yeah I got one like it I
don't like it one of the you know it's
weird the different people who talk to
you in their life when I was selling
cars in 87 bottom
before I got arrested I was out of
control t yeah like I was out of control
on the blow and I knew I had these guys
at the dealership I knew I was a good
salesman and I bought a car from them
one day and I [ __ ] they hit me with
like all these bills additional bills
they tried to rob me and I went and
grabbed the [ __ ] sledgehammer and got
on the cars on the sadly for all the
customers and I said if I don't get my
money in ten minutes I'm gonna start
breaking [ __ ] windshields in here so
they gave me a check and they sent me
home for the day yeah I remember I went
home with this guy called Carlos
Valverde he got busted shortly after
that for bank robbery he was a beautiful
Italian kid Cuban Italian can of Puerto
Rican Italian kid from Boston and he was
a bank robber at lunchtime like he would
rob a bank and let's go launch rob a
bank with his friends and then go back
to work with nothing happened oh man but
they were hooked on heroin these guys
yeah I'll never forget one day he'd get
that day he gave me a ride home he asked
me if he could use the bathroom and he
was in there for [ __ ] an hour oh man
I could tell what Harald was I'd been
around the but the point of the story is
that when I went back to work that
Monday the owner called me in the office
and he sat me down he was his old cool
[ __ ] white dude you know punchy boy
and he looked at me goes and said he
buddy told you because you're one of my
favorite people here might come to work
in the morning sometimes I just sit here
and watch the mothers and watch you out
there [ __ ] around with customers how
you talk to this stuff here because but
maybe able to tell you just a born run
again she's I fell in love with him yeah
because you don't do nothing of what we
tell you here yeah but you still produce
yeah so I what I can't argue with you
I'm the same way Jerry said the Harless
yeah yeah you gotta wear this I'm like
nah you gotta do I did everything I
wouldn't go to sales me ask all the
other cars bro yeah all the workers
would be like well [ __ ] it Dean doesn't
do any of that yeah but Dean sold 18
bikes this week yeah [ __ ] kill them
my god I'm still having them like every
month some
and Anthony Robbins comes in Thai oh
those guys we should say oh the worst
the whole sales force goes like suckers
and you stay there by yourself selling
cause like a [ __ ] while they're
at learning I wasn't into the red [ __ ]
me like I went to one Anthony Robbins
seminar I got robbed
yeah I tried I took the notebook home I
did the exercises I was still snorting
coke it didn't work yeah yeah you know
if the notebook didn't work I'm gonna
give you a thousand to walk on coals
you're [ __ ] crazy I'm gonna burn my
feet [ __ ] walk on coals well you know
the thing about sales man it's you got
to understand survival and if people
don't have survival skills they'll be
terrible at sales because if they've got
like backup plans or money in the bank
or family or whatever they're gonna be
horrible because they don't have any
like I've got to sell this you know it's
really weird
I've enjoyed my life because the
decision I made early on that I wasn't
gonna work for an hourly wage right like
I made a decision early on that here's
my life brother so much you make two
grants and some lunch and make ten but
I'd rather live that uncertainty then
live under an income rule under a thumb
I did not ever want to have $15 an hour
600 a week I know exactly what I was
gonna bring home every week I lived
under budget even back then I wasn't
selling cars at 25 I was reckless in the
sense that if I want to live the way I
want to live I had to sell cars yeah
it's a desperation think it's a survival
thing yep now I'm gonna have to live in
those days first off I had to go to
[ __ ] Coco's everyday and get a burger
and a [ __ ] Coco Loco
yeah that was you know I had to eat
lunch out I had to buy suits I had to
buy clothes out of paper Dyke tried
cleaning I had to pay rent I had to have
a nice place you know it wasn't [ __ ]
the Taj Mahal it was a bedroom I shared
with guys you know yeah a three house
three bedroom house with guys but you
know did I want to do coke five nights a
week I want to be able to go to a bar
and drink 50 bucks so I would make my
own budget and what I had
every month in my head and that's what I
would strive for but most dealers learn
how to you know like most car
dealerships in those days would give you
a draw on the 50
oh man that alone oh it's like a low
yeah so it's like so what do you bills
every monthly my bills on this this okay
I'm gonna give you that over 15,000 but
I'm the dirty that's the wash so
anything if you had any over to you over
all the money no if you didn't always to
double that what they gave you right
that's your goal so what you do is like
people like me and Dean did where the
first two weeks we saw everybody a suck
on deck we were at the concert yeah yeah
we're gone we took that check from the
thirtieth paid our rent and for two
weeks we don't give a [ __ ] you don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
like sales call there's a guy up there
yes a power then pull up filled with
money he's looking to buy a car we're
gonna sell them a car so after you got
that fifteen hundred holla draw now you
gotta make fifteen of us and that's what
I've gotta work yeah because that's when
people buy a car the last two weeks of
the month absolutely the first week is
when they go look they keep tires I'm
looking unless they run into a Salesman
yeah well I learned that term you know
when somebody tells you that I'm buying
a car for six months and also you call
him up two days late and they're like I
bought a car you're like what yeah and
you're like huh I ran into a Salesman
well I got to become a sale but I was
because I was their friend
why not open the hood I didn't try to
close him because I thought [ __ ] you
after that everybody got closed on the
first try yeah I berated you the first
time in there cuz I knew I only had one
shot at you statistically yep do the
stats I know I only got one shot it yeah
there were a few people that you asked
them one time in Marion and you back off
and then you take this coupon and you
take that name and give them a brochure
and you call them up and they come back
two weeks later with that kid and buy
the car yet those people do exist but
80% of the time you got one shot at
these [ __ ] savages that's it so you
got it you don't want [ __ ] all that nice
guys [ __ ] be nice nice nice and then
before they leave you know back I had a
and Tom home he was a loser this guy was
just a loser yeah I was you know yeah we
got a podcast a few weeks ago about
comedy and I really had to think about
it before I came on and I remember when
I got separated I had a spare bedroom I
could not afford this place by myself my
wife moved out and I was first doing
comedy like my mortgage was out of
[ __ ] control compared and he begged
me to move it lady you ain't moving it
with me he was one of these guys that
came here for six months we get in
trouble and go back to Colorado trouble
for settlement and he was he would tell
me all you gotta go to California so
cause you [ __ ] surf half the day and
you sell cars the other half the day
across the street people come in and
give you money for cars by the way let
me Hello us and I'll give it to you on
Tuesday California there's some cars
every day yeah the guy was just betting
the mooch you know but that Duke is so
[ __ ] cop yeah yeah his lifestyle was
drinking drugs he could sell a car cuz
his addiction see those guys are they're
addicted the asset yep those cracked
little [ __ ] you put him on the
phone six hours a day just enough to a
snap yeah till they need that coke rock
again oh come on Gary Glen Ross yeah
always because be closed before the car
I have now I'm not gonna go back there
but I bought two cars from the same
salesman yeah you guys never thought
like oh let me be nice and treating like
once they buy a car look I bought five
cars from this guy six cars do the same
[ __ ] guy up there super I believe in
it I believe in that system
but most people don't have that belief
they're [ __ ] animals
yep and adrylek killed me because this
is the deal like if you live in Studio
City crime over in Studio City right now
and you and I sell cars at Studio City
Subaru and you live in Burbank and you
come into Studio City look at me I'm a
mom and pop operation I can't do the
same deal a big deal of downtown could
do right when you go down those streets
and you see those big dealers like van
highs
do you know there's a thousand cars and
my selling a thousand cars a month so
they'll take smaller deals
I hate those muchas yeah that'll go
across town and pay 300 hours cheaper
for the same car oh and then can't come
to us for service yeah yeah we'll tell
you you can come to us yeah I'll put you
last on the list yeah yeah it's gonna
take you eight hours a service and we're
probably gonna bang you out for
something every time you come in from
being a douche bag
I had this dick one time Joe he came in
and and rocked me for about seven hours
and you know let me see it again in the
Sun it's blue or green do I want blue
green all day out in 110 Sun of [ __ ]
Van Nuys and then the next day he went
to another place and then he rode the
motorcycle over to show me on Monday
Hey look I ended up picking up one you
weren't working yesterday and it just
coolest that we work on Commission I was
like dude I just spent seven hours with
you oh yeah I know but I was like yeah
so after a while you get an attitude
problem
oh man you do I think they know cuz like
being a server and they stiff you want a
tip I think I think everyone has some
people are dumb they think you're
getting paid hourly too or something
like some kind of salary but no it's
pure I'm just always tipped yeah oh hell
I was a kid I've always tipped because
my mother taught me to tip since I was a
kid yeah what's a tip a dollar game -
yeah yeah yeah what's the real tip 20%
of $6 given wait give me the give me the
ten what's the for the whole difference
is gonna make him make somebody's day
yeah that comes back to you tenfold oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah who cares I'm a [ __ ]
10 well then go to these comedy clubs on
the weekends before I leave I take it I
take 420 s yeah I loved those twenties
and then I go to a store and get like
five tens and you get in tens and
twenties those uber drivers I give him a
$10 ten yeah and if I start raining who
gives a [ __ ] and they're happening in
cash it's off the books nobody knows
nothing
yep what am I gonna give him a tip on
the aplex I'm [ __ ] jabroni
laughs no I'm a [ __ ] 5 ain't give a
[ __ ] it you're going out with your girl
you want to impress the [ __ ] girl
throw the guy a 5 you make his night
yeah you're Megan's neck Dave make this
night even if it's a [ __ ] thin your
man [ __ ] night yeah people have no
clue about that that life you know I was
telling somebody we're not in the comedy
business when the karma business yeah
when you're in the plumbing business
you're in the comic business when you're
a massage therapist you're in the common
you're in acupuncture's you're in the
common business okay say I went to the
acupuncture
I told me to tell her for the first time
cuz I remember I got my shoulders have a
little slick lately ever since I've been
kickboxing yeah I have no power in my
budget I'm an old man I'm not looking at
knock nobody out but because the
extension hurts a little bit on the way
out and lately I've been falling asleep
on them and they kinda hurt oh yeah he
put some meals and he caught me he goes
all right let's get out of here and also
he goes wait up are you gonna rush I got
like this let's cup your shoulders yeah
that's priceless yeah how about that's
priceless on the x-term I think you know
when I go to jujitsu and class is from
12 to 115 and you're still there to roll
them when you teach it you know there
was a place I went to look that one day
and the guy told me he goes class doctor
12 I don't want nobody hit til five til
12 oh I'm gonna forget that I was like
you know what I don't need to come here
yeah yeah they're not a real teacher
yeah you're just fighting just the
[ __ ] twenty minutes and bro if class
would end that seven to one he would end
the five to one and he'd have a suit on
at 105 and he'd be out the door you got
to stick around and that's a question
then roll around with the students and
yeah and that's why he had a shitty
school and he didn't know that he wasn't
in the time business he's in the [ __ ]
common business
yeah he's trying to sell minutes well
how do you guys deal with people truly
in the Karma business when people treat
you poorly how do you how do you stay
positive and be likable and like not
give up like [ __ ] it everywhere people
don't shoot like this and I'll just give
them them one of the greatest lines
that's ever said in the movie was in
Bronx town
when the kids pissed because that
[ __ ] kid owes me 20 bucks he goes it
cost you 20 hours to get rid of them
yeah yeah I got three or four people who
I lent money to our kindness in my heart
and every will call back to say a
friendly [ __ ] you
yep that's it you know what I know you
broke these yeah you come to me three
times or $50 if I give you 300 and you
come to me three times of fifty dollars
three weeks in a row on a Friday like
you said you were going to I'm the type
of guy that says hey forget the other
yard now yeah I know you're going to
rough times I know I'm taking a lot out
of you by this 50 I just want you to
stick to your man word that's it you
know for three years I was opposed for
years I was a [ __ ] Punk I was a
[ __ ] Punk because I was snorting
cocaine and it was letting me do things
that was against my manhood then if
something happened I became a man like
those Indians like the man Kulish what
says he is I didn't have to go to rehab
I didn't have to I made a decision and
then I had made other decisions in my
life
that's will is to become a man is making
decisions sticking by them and that's it
this is the decision I've made and I
live and I die by it that's why the song
my way by Frank Sinatra is so [ __ ]
emotional because at the end of the day
you know what a Winston Churchill say
success is moving from one area to
another area and staying excited about a
subject that's something like that he
made a great quote right you know we
live in the same in the same room we do
podcasts I do a movie I do a TV show one
week then we go on the road for a week
and then I don't want I never really
wanted a job I love going on the road
when you do it for weeks in a row it
becomes a job yeah yeah your job that
fifth week you like I don't know whether
they take this week yeah yeah yeah and
it's a hell week that you didn't want
but you took it because of the money
these are choices that you learn about
later on yeah
when to stop becoming a [ __ ] you have
to be a [ __ ] first to stop becoming a
hard yeah you don't say absolutely be a
[ __ ] to stop being a [ __ ] 100% on that
[ __ ] that I had in me for for calmly
when I stopped being a [ __ ] I became a
comic but the [ __ ] 10 years you got
to be a [ __ ] yeah you know yeah hey 200
when you know the guys walking with
$3,000 you know you gotta take the small
200 cuz in your mind you're saying to
yourself you might have got this 3000
but you're only gonna do this three more
times ten years from now I'm gonna get
three thousand fifteen three years yeah
yeah so that's what happens now that's
how your mind looks at it when you
become a man
yeah I'm saying I was a [ __ ] in comedy
we did everything we come back when we
got off a plane at six
we're on stage at eight for buck fifty
somewhere that's me every week tired
tired over ya know shower or our plane
ride
nothing about another spot yeah it's a
spot it's a spot but that's for anything
when you first start painting yeah I
mean you first don't paint them till you
get discovered you sell those pictures
for ten dollars
one day you're sending your apartment
you're like I'm getting 3,000 thousands
of pictures I wish I could go back and
lock on Deans door and get my 290 you
know say like yeah but you had to do
that to put it out there you got to do
it man it's like you know [ __ ] I flew
in from what uh Nashville Sunday morning
9:30 straight to the house start
podcasting you know then then do a spot
then go see Judas Priest it's just like
you got to keep moving when you're at
that stage because you know somebody
else if you say no to the spot somebody
else is gonna say yeah and then the call
stop you know yeah
that's what's weird when the calls hit
the call stop so you gotta always go
yeah I'm there I'm there even though I
know I'm gonna be completely tore up but
I get something I leave tonight
yeah we've got exactly the attitude I'll
sleep that night I'll sleep tonight man
and that's it last month the you
you invited me to do a show with you
that I left there blown away oh great
press on what you did there was the
ac/dc reunion like a he's got a reunion
and of Slon Scott trivia the Bon Scott
tribute and uh he left myself and Bill
and Mary hair and be a [ __ ] part of
the shot was a little upset cuz he'll
everybody else play on stage and you
usually give me a flute something I
gotta play the flute on Soul strippers
but it was just such a [ __ ] electric
night Dean and I still want to thank you
because but I told the podcasters before
my people who listened that made me
realize that I was missing live music
last night I was pissed when you text me
yeah and said you were in priest I was
like god dammit yeah but what I have
really come on after a show I'm dying
right now the baby jumped me as soon as
I that's what I figured you weren't
there you know the baby Joe listen to
Columbus after three days it's like yeah
as soon as I walk in now she's right I
walked in at nine o at night in the
morning Oh in the morning hey we're
leaving at 1000 so that first hour she
was all over me Tanya by the week the
pictures we hung up pictures my office
is just covered in [ __ ] kid pictures
yeah and then they left which gave me
two hours to run my errands fill up the
tank get some weed I went to the bed and
got the [ __ ] chemotherapy and did you
I wanting a little [ __ ] acai juice
whatever the [ __ ] yeah I said what you
juicing I got some compulsion yeah and
then I went home and I just did my
weekly errands put the schedule together
for the week of [ __ ] and they came back
Chloe need at 1:30
like I usually thinking that wasn't
happy yeah he came in that door right to
the office started with octonauts
oh my TV show and we
up in her room watched another movie
didn't add a tick over frozen yogurt
yeah and we sat in there for 35 minutes
talking my life at her birthday party
it's a year away oh wow a year away yeah
she's already planning for six year old
birthday but so [ __ ] January yeah yeah
and then we went home we watched another
movie you know and then she won the tub
and I'm the one that's got a Drano it's
just one of those nights I don't know if
I leave I disrupt the whole patois the
[ __ ] evening so now after nine if I
got a gun somewhere last night I
would've gone to the store I thought
about going down to the store Redman was
doing the show but back to your your low
ac/dc tribute I mean you just had a
[ __ ] insane lineup tell of his crazy
use issues I had seen before but didn't
really know right but it didn't matter
the guy behind the drums were
sensational yeah you know you had the
two bass players of death Nikki Sixx and
Rudy Sarzo unbelievable uh you know you
had [ __ ] the guy playing the guitar
Oh Josh Z from San Francisco that guys
doing the English Lit you could tell he
had bought power rage when the first
came out yeah like he had been playing
that song he was a real [ __ ] Angus guy
like know that like thirty years yeah he
was solid I'm the [ __ ] Angus licks he
was solid as can be I mean I sat there
in the sidelines and I was like I didn't
know what to expect but I wasn't
expecting that yeah yeah he knows I was
expecting that at all I was expecting
six [ __ ] guys smoking the boys room
type of attitude yeah [ __ ] notes
being thrown back vocals it is tight you
were tight you were very tight you know
oh man we only rehearsed one night to
the night before you know but those guys
are all pros you know Steve played in
the Black Crowes for you know his whole
life and and then Michael Devon putting
Whitesnake the bass player and then you
know Billy Rowe from chip boy who'd been
on stage his whole life doing the
Malcolm and then of course got Ian from
anthrax who's a Malcolm freak and has
Malcolm tattooed on him and
and and plays rhythm guitar like Malcolm
these guys all they got to do is throw
on the record for you know an hour I go
oh yeah okay goes there and there and
there and then we stepped onstage and it
was you never know what's gonna happen
gear can break people could leave not
show up whatever you know cuz we did
when I was 50 and everybody came for the
comedy and then when we did the ac/dc a
lot of people left really yeah I think
his it was a it was huge mostly comedy
fans of that one because it was at the
time my podcast wasn't as big as it is
now so it didn't have as many
rock-and-rollers but this time if you
look at the photos the first three four
rows people are all wearing ac/dc shirts
and I went to the front door when they
open the front door and I was greeting
everybody as they came in people are
flew in from you know Florida Tampa
Detroit Portland Philly New York guys
came from all over the place for this
thing it was pretty emotional for me
because I was like wow this is this is
insane you know I mean I couldn't
believe it
we got a pro video if you look at it
I've kicked in the teeth again with bird
on drums Nikki Sixx on bass it's on
YouTube and I think it's one of my
favorite hands-down top favorite three
things I've ever done in my life
it was just loony you know and then you
crushed it doing comedy you were
crushing it it was crushin that was it
was a horrible set oh it's great I made
some girl cry Oh or upset Oh people love
dead [ __ ] upset
I could tell really sighs his wife was
looking at me we
oh no way you had a great man you got a
great day one like this said about me
talking about molesting my wife they
froze they were rockers but they were
still that's right they didn't know like
what the [ __ ] but I had a great night I
didn't even care about the set I was
just started to be part of it and just
to uh god I loved you having you there
it's 40 year anniversary of power age
for 20 [ __ ] years and in two years
will be 40 years that Bond's God past so
I used to do this ac/dc tribute to bond
every year in San Francisco because it
was right around the time of my birthday
my birthday's February 3rd he died on
that I believe the 16th close the late
teens on my 1999 um I broke a Dinan your
birthday so every year I would do this
and then when I moved to LA I didn't
really do it anymore because I just
didn't have you know no he died in
February of 80 right yep February of 80
and then the back and black comes out
like six months later
um but yeah I'm a big ol to seen him
August 2nd
right there yeah August 1st in the
Palladium of 80 79 80 80
laughter he died yeah yeah he died and
six months later they I had a [ __ ]
that how I still remember buying it and
hearing it the whole [ __ ] like it
didn't stop it is what I'm like [ __ ]
fire flamethrower to it it really did
it's really bizarre like when you think
about how no band has lost a singer got
a new singer and sold a hundred million
records it's the number two selling
record of all time I believe behind
thriller to do that is insane that they
you can't even add up the odds of that
there's just no [ __ ] way you know hey
here's a record with a new singing a new
singer I mean I never knew it was
- number two behind thriller yeah I
think it's got the egos thriller back in
Black Eagles Greatest Hits I believe is
that have you read the new Bon Scott
book I have about bond writing the stuff
yeah I believe he wrote that record 100%
what is the conflict with the book
there's no conflict that what it is is I
heard that it was the book reveals that
he wanted to quit ac/dc
yeah I mean but we're also going off of
interviews of friends you know like when
you hang out and maybe you have a long
run of shows and you go you know I don't
think I want to do stand-up anymore and
you tell me that and then and then next
day you're normal people say stuff like
a day every dream right right so I then
give you interview a guy who was bonds
friend you know and he's like yeah I
don't know about this I don't want to
leave the band
you don't ever take that to heart people
have weird that you know weird things go
on and we have insecurities yeah yeah we
do so whether it's see a singer a bass
player you know in your mind things just
become bigger you know you see the drugs
and the alcohol don't help no your
impression of yourself for what you're
doing you know I mean that didn't
helping at that time he was the biggest
[ __ ] jammy on that band I think Angus
is young yeah
angus is clean right yeah yeah never
drank about this why coca-cola tea
cigarettes that's it yep yeah like that
type of [ __ ] but bond was a different
level yeah you know I spoke to Josh wolf
last week and he was talking about how
he got lid on - let there be rock the
out oh yeah believe how good yeah this
that whole thing and you know when I
read their stuff and I found that that
you know whole lot of rosy was a true
chick right he really did [ __ ] a fat
chick one night and he wrote if I mean
he wrote all those lyrics a lot of them
right yeah
oh hi % % of the writing and he did what
we do he told the story in his songs he
was a brilliant [ __ ] drunk oh just
you know hit yesterday had power rage on
yeah believe this I can't believe those
lyrics all right all that [ __ ] is just
overdose over one of my all-time
favorite [ __ ] song ah that's on let
there be rock and uh overdose it's
incredible and then I'm a power raids
they also have a type of a ballad oh
well I'm powerage they have well it to
buy oh yeah give me a Bullitt East
Christ yeah Jesus Christ
I'll make believe it's you oh my god
Jesus Christ he just popped up with some
[ __ ] that was just uh it was funny cuz
this morning when I got up I got I've
been 559 on the dot yeah I can always
tell when you're up late coffee I called
you like it said back of a [ __ ] jug I
don't care how late he was to sleep over
get up [ __ ] after all we get the
quality conversations Oh before the
motors man get up [ __ ] the motor is
moving I've already done a cup and a
half of coffee I rest my five PI pills
I've chewed to pieces and nicotine gum
really I've answered tweeted my agents
know what to do for the week they got
the instructions for the week they're
all sent on missions yeah yeah I told
one agent I better have my [ __ ] money
today I don't give a [ __ ] what they
gotta do hey and I got home from
kickboxing and the thing was there an
overnight that said on Friday awesome
check from Santa Hannah I started gotten
paid what yeah it killed me sometimes
well that's why I told him I said hey
man I pay you deposit when I get back I
give you the Commission quickly so his
no misunderstanding yeah I've heard of
clients getting behind uh-oh
what they end up owing
weeks let's dumb move you got to do it
immediately or else it's hard to give
get it out of your pocket you know
where's that [ __ ] Tony Bennett bleep
Matt the blue sis Nicolas Jorgenson
Elliott Smith bad [ __ ] Chris way
ouki spooky fire got his bet my main man
UFC Arabic [ __ ] Adam Pistone my
brother from Chicago blah blah Lingus
and a happy birthday to my brother who
came out to the shows in Columbus J bish
over there and [ __ ] Pittsburgh
running things is [ __ ] you know I'm
saying sometimes people start running
things so now are you thinking of doing
this ACP again next year you know I I
was talking to BER about it and I was
thinking like I mean I'm such a lunatic
but that thing was pretty big and it got
a lot of press and it was done it was
done out of the heart and written and
and just fun I was thinking it's gonna
be 40 year anniversary of Bon Scott gone
there's a way we could do it like at the
Forum like a big big [ __ ] with me you
Marren a bird on comedy again and like
some like just a collection of cool rock
stars like Josh Homme it Queens of the
Stone Age let's say Nikki Sixx again
good you know guys that uh you know Dave
Grohl Dave Grohl would be great on
something like this some big dudes and
really pump it for a couple months and
do the form you know Bertha there's a
way where they can seed it for like six
thousand but to make up full a full
tribute one big one more big daddy for
Bon Scott like the best singer ever man
really glorify it for bond you know I
think that would be rad so long like
when you had your bands yeah was bond a
big influence in your music huh idea I
got him tattooed on my [ __ ] body
I mean what you know when I saw ac/dc
the first time I saw him was on the
powerage tour and in 78 and when
I saw him everybody was into Angus that
was cool Angus was cool but to me it was
like what's up with that dude up there
he had tattoos no one had tattoos big ol
parrot he had that weird vest on no
shirt and he was up there I got and I
was like what that guys like a [ __ ]
outlaw you know I was attracted to him
you know Angus was cool but to me I was
like what's up with that dude man I've
never seen a guy like that before
just even he looked like he worked for
the band yeah
funny because when I when I caught him
in 80 or seven 78 79 yeah I win a home
tour oh yeah 79 August 4th of 79 with
priests no with Ted Oh Ted opening yeah
that's right hopefully for Ted
I still remember like how great they
were but him running around the audience
would hang us on his show nobody was
doing that no but nobody was doing that
no and he did that degree this arena of
the world at that time like news spread
it was the New York Daily News the next
day and like you know yeah you on the
show I haven't been looking at I would
always look at there was something that
gave me review with shows I know what
comes a magazine or a newspaper right
and it's saying that this is one of the
best shows that have come to New York
and it for the first time in a long time
it wasn't the headline who like I still
remember the review on Van Halen
Whiteside oh yeah yeah and they were the
headline was like Black Sabbath is
broken yeah yeah and I was like shocked
cause I thought the same thing when I
left there that night like something
wasn't right yeah either that or Van
Halen was that good yeah I think as a
combo bomb yeah
it was a combo boat so this sometimes
shows that you don't know when you leave
that if Black Sea you know at that time
like every time I saw arrow submit they
were just bad yeah I could see him with
a [ __ ] preschool group with the
[ __ ] 4th annual quintet band and they
were [ __ ] bad they were sloppy music
was off-key yeah like one time I saw him
at the Meadowlands and we laughed yeah
like we would never so bad we had to
leave like
we gotta go you gotta go
this is [ __ ] terrible they just could
not cut it and then I went again it's
just so weird how you make I want to go
to I want to go see now that Michael
Shanklin come nobody went yeah I came he
it was you and I had just got home from
where were we last Santa Hannah that no
no we flew home from some all
Albuquerque it was that day and it was
the week of the Bon Scott thing so I was
tore up so we did what was it was so you
and I did the ac/dc thing then we flew
immediately to Albuquerque we did the
three shows then we flew home and I was
just dust you know it was just like uh I
wanted to go but it was all the way down
there at Orange County it's not enough I
want to go to the Hollywood Bowl the Sun
I'm getting in whatever you want to see
it shows to you what it was coming I'll
send Louis - lets get the [ __ ] line
up yeah help them let's see what the
[ __ ] schedule yeah we gotta get you
in there the church concerts where you
go and that a bit rare get more research
on Verado and make some pens yeah right
I saw him last night it was cool to see
him there was a lot of rock rockers
there last night man Tom Morello was
there Kerry King from Slayer everybody
was out to see the priest last night man
you know they know and then priests just
uh they just announced the summer tour
with deep purple
yeah with Ian Gillan oh man we want to
see that I don't know I don't know if
I'd go see deep purple Ritchie
Blackmore's creepiest he's not in there
anymore I got that a guy from Dixie
dregs okay here we go so there's the
start of the season I'm really bummed I
missed net yeah yes Paul Simon's coming
I don't want you for now no I'm Kevin
Hart dude Wow that'd be wild to see that
in there
Oh Rod Stewart Cyndi Lauper yeah you
know wanted the grease sing-along Joey
ah
where's Rod Stewart Cyndi Lauper that's
June 25 26 Wow yeah dude might have to
see that but we're doing VAE
yes when is that it's at that same time
no 12 - okay I got it
okay got it keep going down let's look
here let's say Annie that's the page -
let's see page - I can't even see this
yeah Randy Newman wanna help
that's short people gonna be a little
short people God I'm gonna go to that
paid out $40 to see one [ __ ] song
yeah Harry Connick jr. Dave Matthews no
yeah yeah no Oh Beck Oh Ozzie oh man
we'll go to that Ozzy and Stone Sour
October 11th let's go to that what do
you think yeah who Stokes our stone
towers the guy from you know the band
that wears the mask he has his own band
it's the singer yeah and and then Ozzy
that would be a good one Beck would be
great I guess see that but that you know
like they add in stuff Joyce oh yeah
yeah yeah right exactly exactly
oh man yeah like you guys I always hear
people talk about their favorite comedy
clubs performing yeah but what like what
like if you guys could see a concert
anywhere where would you guys go so
where would you'd like to see a concert
oh man Red Rocks is the number one man
is where I saw a couple bands that was a
great spot
man listen let's let's let's be honest
there's some places that are
aesthetically cool yeah like Red Rocks
is an aesthetically cool pea place and
miraculously the sound is phenomenal now
I rage but there's just places that are
just right yeah
I don't know that Gorge in Seattle you
ever go there yeah I went that one time
and I was that was nice yeah you know I
really liked Madison Square Garden yeah
but I really I really liked smaller
venues the film was my favorite on the
planet and my god we've discussed before
I was always a palladium guy oh yeah in
New York City I don't know what it's sad
at that time what the Palladium in New
York said at that time 19 in the CIC
yeah 1980 capacity at the Palladium
Theatre palladiums yeah New Yorker New
Jersey New York City legendary man
palladium because I can't I can't
imagine that place being 1,800 and
that's what we that's where I saw Ozzie
and [ __ ] Judas Priest and I saw Iron
Maiden there on the first album and I
saw
oh no no killers killers oh so called
the animal I saw an array of bands there
and the DEF LEPPARD I saw behind dry eye
and I think Allah know I'm through the
night go on through the night rad on
through the night and then high and dry
I thought I got a think I got a think
I'm dry saw them a couple times they'll
probably be hard to find I think I think
I found it I think is this 3400 yeah
yeah sorry yeah can you imagine seen
Judas Priest oh man Ozzy Osbourne a
place that holds 3400 seats
yeah like how lucky was I and then all
right how was the other one think if you
saw them somewhere else will it be
50,000 will be down yeah yeah that's a
lot of sound that's a lot of bounce
there's a lot of [ __ ] detraction
that's a lot of people in the audience
it's a lot of noise to see somebody in a
3400 seat theater is like going to a
movie theater yeah it was was just a big
movie theater yeah that's like the
Warfield and San Fran I saw everybody
there you know what does it see do you
think I think it's a twenty eight
hundred or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's funny because I did
it with Russell Peters a couple years
ago when I was a kid I played there
opening up for a band bad English and
then years later I did it as a comedian
I go oh this place is small like when
you're a kid it seems huge right I like
to play them seemed huge when you're a
kid English with John wait yeah open
forum yeah I'm missing you in a forum
yeah that band or was it later on yeah
bad English that was he had a good band
it was bad English was a band that got
put together was like two from what one
band
yeah they Neal Sean right yeah man and
the drummer Deen Castronovo saw my band
and said man you guys gotta open for us
and with the reopen forum like the next
night at the Warfield you know we're
just kids right cool [ __ ] we thought
were you I was like 20 you know 18 19
right around there something I know 21
or whatever but I thought oh man we're
on our way we're playing the Warfield
then what was the pay up but something
like that in those days we hopefully
it's always like 750 500 guys yeah four
guys but we would have done that for
free dude you know the bragging rights
around town like to play the war field
or the film or back then as a local
unsigned band that's like a big deal man
that's like a big deal because you know
sign bands would bring other bands there
was never any happen in you know spots
but they didn't have a band opening for
him so we got to do it man it was I
still remember it like it was yesterday
it's amazing the sacrifices like yeah
you're right that's why leave and I were
talking about the triple run earlier
yeah you know everyone I go I think we
that you're not ready mentally Oh triple
run because it's don't take you out it's
a little big difference of a change it's
like a weekend you think it'd be crazy
yeah just just a driving just it would
be crazy for you because you couldn't
believe you're doing Tommy at this place
yeah they still doing this Jerry yeah
they still do them you know my thing
there was a place in western Jim
I walked in one time it was a ping-pong
table I had to get on top a stands one
started buckling on three on your
[ __ ] path
oh my god India's something at the time
1998 you can't really handle that at the
time I was doing Kylie yeah I was at the
store already and I wrote but I remember
walking in there go what did I [ __ ]
silent me yeah yeah his creative
entertainment was out of Charlotte Yap
time they run the Charlotte Club they
have a club and they have a couple clubs
but back then their specialty which is
still he still has a few left on in
there in the 90s he had hundreds of one
night Wow hundreds right like berry cat
style just all over berry add those all
over the East Coast are you heard and he
would send all these guys out on these
right you would have those college yeah
yeah just these places but you don't
know what hell is till you get there
you know when you go to DC it's
completely different than going on with
off city in West Virginia
yeah well they're all coal miners and
they don't have mascara on they're
looking at here home estate and you're
like holy [ __ ] I mean they've call their
face then I'm gonna scare on them hold
on their face they just got on the
[ __ ] coal mine huh you can't handle
that and they're not gonna like the
jokes that I've been doing or jokes that
I have yeah how many you got four
probably something like that maybe that
I've done no don't eat you up alive
after the eighth minute
yeah your legs will start trembling once
you say you're Jewish and the room stops
laughing have that yeah you know ya know
that's a that's a four year you have to
be doing comedy three three years and
really like gonna like off nights in
places yeah
Bakersfield I did a lot of Bakersfield I
did a lot of patrolling Bakersfield has
a great little comedy scene they really
know I'll have to head over there for
one hour and a half away
right over the grapevine I don't wanna
[ __ ] very much even it's not even I
wanna know
you start learning all kinds of [ __ ]
because you're over there man you know I
did say knees the first time this
weekend it was the Nashville Comedy
Festival how great is that club in that
girl Lucy she loves you man she'd man
that those guys
reached out to me this is old school
this is how I always think the business
should work they see I'm coming with
burr and they go hey would you like to
do some sets because we know you're only
doing one set a night you'll be sitting
in your hotel room would you like to
come do some sets and [ __ ] reached
out to me I was like meh this is how I
thought it was gonna be years ago like
whoa he came with Joey's great well
booked you for months from now I thought
that's how it was gonna be and they
reached out and I went and did say knees
all weekend they had a brunch show it
was [ __ ] fantastic sold-out Saturday
at two o'clock just kill her audiences
oh man it was great man you done that
room right yeah yeah yeah it's funny I
was telling Dave the owner of the
Columbus comedy club today mr. James
true how much comedy has changed because
cities have grown right let me tell you
something my friends 15 years ago yeah
you would have not come home with a
pleasant oh man I bet you would have
done okay yeah it's guys like me at the
time yeah
always gotta remember that's a Bible
Belt that's right a dragon that what
happens in the Bible Belt is they take
the rider for 15 minutes from your blue
yeah they take the ride of your for
about 11 minutes yeah and then there's a
comedian a young comic you always make
the mistake of pushing the envelope a
little more gas down and that one
reminds them that they're Christian yeah
can't laugh at that and now the next 17
minutes it's just people staring at you
like you're a sinner then Stanhope went
up yeah and his first 12 minutes were
tremendous yeah and they sat there for
40 instead of him they weren't onto his
antics at all wow I was maybe 150 people
who know about Stanhope that were in the
show that night yeah this has to be 99
Wow and you're opening and I'm opening
and I remember that I did so bad yeah
I never even considered calling that guy
every gal like I knew what the answer
was gonna be there's no there's no lying
to yourself that point I was doing
comedy eight nine years and the line had
stopped like Hawaiian stop me have like
two years I knew I sucked and I know how
to work on it right and you have to go
on stage every night
liked it whatever thing I had that
things are going great went away yeah
you know yeah now you have to start
working it was so weird that I walked
into that room and never ever ever
thought I did so bad yeah I never even
went back there with Joe why Joe would
go there and I go I'm not going back
there
yeah yeah and the older is such a nice
guy
oh the second thing I didn't like
because nobody could be that [ __ ]
nice right
wasn't nobody is that nice right now and
at the time 15 years ago his other
brother who is now very nice yeah he's
always there there were great guys but
his brother home the club in Davie
Florida right which is a suburb right
out for a lot of damage with the Miami
Dolphins practice right and that Club
was all understand me wow this is way
before the improper started right and he
had a club in West Palm Beach and one in
Davie yeah West Palm was I bombed the
bag of dicks there oh not as bad as
Nashville yeah right
I had one in there one night because I
worked with Marsha Warfield yep and I
got in trouble cuz I'm gonna grab a Coke
in the waitstaff and they hated me and
they [ __ ] blackballed me so after the
bombing in Nashville and the situation
in West Palm I knew there was no if they
ever got together and they gonna work
Joe Davis at my club took the worst
Bobby in the world uh-huh then the other
brother would say is that my club didn't
do that well I'm Wally gram the blow
from the waitstaff yeah I got in trouble
for it really yeah the manager came to
you by Grandma blow for why would you
summit snitch job he sold coke too right
so he came in to [ __ ] at me for not -
yeah and I should have gotten to him and
brought it to him then he ratted me out
well I was the creepiest thing in the
[ __ ] world with
the beginning of your comedy career yeah
yeah right yeah so to think of a stretch
Nashville has made I could headline
there yeah people show up and laugh
right like it is really like I would
never like I tell you another night I
took a tremendous bomb another club I
had a bag of dicks at Charlotte oh yeah
Charles died on a Sunday night in 1998
yeah on the way out of town
I took the late continental flight
continental was still around oh yeah
they hobbed in Charlotte Oh
so IRA flying out of Charlotte if we're
confident it was ten bucks
Wow like around the country anywhere how
the Charlotte was cheap but to
California it's like $59 I took the late
flight to do a set at that [ __ ]
Charlotte Club like I guess that like I
called the club oh I'm gonna coming in
rock new world yeah and I took the
beating of death in there oh hey I'd
even shake his hand I just went outside
got a cab yeah and went right to the
airport and at five hours six hour
flight home was brutal oh I had just
bombed got went right from the club I
put a [ __ ] plane from the stage to
the planes a page to the plane with a
bombing with a beaten I had taken one of
the roughest beatings that week in my
life the Unabomber because here you are
in the comedy school you're a regular at
the store yeah you're supposed to be the
elite of the elite yeah and you're just
dying oh but I put together that it was
the Bible right and when I went to
creative and did the one-nighters that's
where you go deeper into the Bible Belt
and that's where like that's where like
we went to Knoxville and the chicken
ratted me out for sucking my dick when I
started yelling in the bag yeah like
that whole week was a nightmare quiet
something Tennessee there's an army base
there or something knocking okay no no
was something to Tennessee right yeah I
did okay at the army base like this is
20 years later yeah and I'm telling you
guys I did okay there as a headline yeah
there was one Friday night where I just
took an emotional beatin on stage
I lost him at the 5-minute mark oh man
another time Jimmy Schubert yeah it's
kind of movie he got the movie go and he
had to cancel wears leather skin from a
Gainesville
what's this city on thumping Gainesville
um [ __ ] real crazy place
I forget okay so our Gainesville housing
Tallahassee Gainesville area no no the
new guy no no that's Tennessee yeah yeah
he had a cancel on a [ __ ] Monday he
got the call at 3 o'clock yeah so how
was the only person that was available
so I took the gig that's how I met Vinny
light boat was really Coppola who lives
around the corner from here right now
his father owns an electrical company
okay that's all my table there we go but
uh he I went down there was a headliner
Oh Jacksonville Jackson go oh that's it
yeah Oh was that a mistake
uh uh I had maybe 40 maybe 40 minute
maybe right right with with lots of
laughs yes yeah yeah I called Doug
Stanhope I got Doug I got a Doug was
fought popular diner at the time uh-huh
I'll never forget this
Doug was popular at the time my dog was
starting to get popular on the road and
because Doug would [ __ ] go down to
these clubs and cause havoc in these
cities he would go to karaokes and do
more stand-up yeah after a lot of a club
so the legend of Doug Stanhope when he
you know when Rogan goes into his city
goes into the best steakhouse in the
city right he tips out for people to
yard stick a piece the word gets out
yeah awesome ticket sales go up 20%
because he gave up and gave fallen our
bills for tips of four different waiters
you know Stanhope went to a bar and
caused just yeah like if it was karaoke
go up then do like the [ __ ] dirtiest
jokes in the world he can get thrown out
you know in the beginning from ninety
you know from 95 to 2000 three bucks
demo was a legend on the road kicking
ass for no TV show that's rad it was
unheard of because
his albums were phenomenal yeah in those
early albums were really [ __ ]
phenomenal I love that cat man yeah like
but this was when he was reeling a
little bit more roaring rounder and I
had more energy when he was famous just
a smartass a comedy he was just a
perfect smartass economy and I'm gonna
call him up and go I need your advice
they just offered me a headlining week
and I got Doug I maybe got 40 minutes
singers I've been around yeah a lot he
goes I'm sure you come up with 20
[ __ ] minutes off the top you had to
take the [ __ ] week take a chance who
gives a [ __ ] yeah do 40 and run off the
stage I mean he used to give the best
advice yeah do 40 lives yeah cuz he was
so reckless he didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
that's what he went for is make them
talk - [ __ ] it are you gonna go down
there make him talk go crazy yeah yeah
sorry yeah I know that I went down and
took that that's when comedy was Tuesday
through sadly Oh Friday night is
all-you-can-eat seafood night they're
all [ __ ] I come in from all over just
for the free seafood they come in there
stop burping those old [ __ ] shrimps
hurricane shrimp urban hurt oh you have
no idea you up on stage mouths [ __ ] grab
like burps and [ __ ] farts that's not
like butter
I'm all the butter there in the crab
legs then that like they haven't had
shrimp their whole life oh yeah and then
go up to her peeling shrimp that drives
some people crazy yeah that [ __ ] drives
people crazy I think they're in [ __ ]
Venice wrong
yeah put in that [ __ ] cut cocktail
sauce eating them whole shrimp a day
before they go rotten Corral they're in
there [ __ ] eat no softie you ever get
them like they have a little coating on
them that's correct
don't take a chance you're rubbery yeah
because you don't give a [ __ ] you'll get
free yeah like a pill it's amazing what
you eat when you don't have money
because it's
the road owners 99 72 oh I'll tell you
what nobody like the MPM burger better
than Joey D oh I think worship busted on
him I can eat two of those truckin
things by the airport there oh yeah when
I was a trope [ __ ] I go in there right
before I went to the airport
Oh had inhaled two of those burgers with
onions on him forgot those [ __ ]
powders aside the quad would not
McDonald's you know what I did that
cross street from the whiskey a go go
they had the am/pm there for years and
now it's called Hawaiian gas or whatever
but I would get the burger and then I've
when the guy wasn't looking I hit the
nacho cheese and just pump of [ __ ]
gallon of nacho cheese on each burger
and then put jalapenos
two bucks [ __ ] disgusting where are
you at soon where are you traveling to
Mexico I'm about to headline San
Francisco punchline what date May 2nd
through the 5th beautiful oh and I'll be
at the Tempe improv May 3rd through the
5th so we both got Cinco DeMayo gigs
Tempe I'm coming big boom back home
where it all started to be a [ __ ]
feature act there me I used to do the
[ __ ] Latino shows that the Reform
minute 20-minute spots and I thought I
was hot [ __ ] now I'm headlining Tempe
she's right rad you're killing it I'm
out there with it you're killing what
happened great your drawers insane the
people are great the table for the
church family is on top of things a
dream man it's a dream right there where
you show up and the shows are already
sold out yeah no no it's beautiful so
Tempe I'll see you down and then I think
the 19th or the 17th of May I'm up in
Providence at the club up there that
whole weekend I'm at the stress factory
in New Jersey with your boy Matt [ __ ]
Voltron you know I'm saying yeah so be a
fun fact weekend there in May the 18th
through the 20th to something like that
you gotta check the website and what I'm
gonna [ __ ] it is but forget about that
right now let's just worry about Tempe
and have a [ __ ] party down there I
want to talk to you guys about something
real quick for the last five years I've
been friends with this girl online you
know she used to hit me up and
said nothing battlemind she had a
boyfriend that we talked to her and her
boyfriend the boyfriend would hit me up
and I would go to Minneapolis and she
would show up and I got to meet her
twice you know and the last time I got
to me that I could tell that progress
she had a disease that she didn't tell
me about in the progress oh wow a little
bit she's a proud girl she's a sweet
girl my name is Brandi Lynn and today I
put a link up on Twitter and YouTube to
YouTube pages if anybody needs help
it's this girl I known her for five
years this is not a scam retweet this is
not a scam you guys know I don't call
you guys for church help for [ __ ]
scammers this is a health situation here
I'm thinking of taking Dean and going up
there and doing a Wednesday two shows at
though House of comedy and like give him
half the [ __ ] door or something like
that yes yeah yeah she's a church family
girl and I already saw people pour their
hearts out you know fire on was $2 to
$10 it all adds up guys so with a church
family you know and I know who's faking
the funk and I know it was really part
of the church family if they need help
we got to do whatever we can to help him
up like I said two dollars helps a
dollar help Lee and I donated this
morning from the church and do what you
can
I love you guys I'll be back Wednesday
with my man Gregorius BJJ [ __ ] Savage
Nick my glorious went to a tremendous
podcast on BJJ he's doing a seminar at a
subconscious BJJ on Lankershim in North
Hollywood Thursday night at 7:00 p.m.
you do not want to miss it if you're in
the valley anywhere he's [ __ ] great
this guy held him with all my heart you
know I'm not the best jujitsu guy but I
I still go when I try my best and that's
all we could do I want to thank Dean
downer I want to thank you guys for put
me on the easy yeah it was an honor to
myself of being a hustler and for always
bringing great conversation love on the
church brother love during this fire
great and go see him in San Francisco
you know we
yup death and the church loves you go
support Dean dowry up there the [ __ ]
punchline punchline yeah that's the
whole that's the homie [ __ ] club right
there oh you and I did it together last
year and your flight was delayed and
they still stayed and watched me happy
that was because it was the foggiest
night ever ever Oh ever
that was insane so that's what this
church is about it's about helping each
other out and [ __ ] know we're good
thank you buddy
so that's it man have a great day we'll
be back Wednesday I love you stay black
I want to thank Dean I want to leave you
with a tremendous [ __ ] Jam by Rod
Stewart one of my favorite kick this
[ __ ] meal Lee don't forget go to
honor calm right now press in church get
10% off and if you're a fat [ __ ] are you
just looking for a great [ __ ] guy
with a great fit durable if your money's
captain right now and you need a key go
to Fuji Sports calm right now at the
church and get 10% off your geek or your
restaurant or whatever the hell you're
looking for I have a great [ __ ] day
stay black uncle Joey loves you